all right so today I'm going to talk
about uh an interesting subtask of
sentiment analysis target-based
sensitive analysis and Google's recent
model T5 so let's Dive In
I'm not going to talk about the outline
so before talking about what sentiment
is and what T5 is actually I wanted to
introduce that like last year Google
announced about their new uh search
algorithm a mom which is the multitask
unified model and they've changed the
words to T5 essentially all two of the
models are Google's Publications but
they they're claiming that it it's 1 000
times more powerful than birth and since
T5 can also generate text it's more
powerful and also it's a trained across
75 different languages and it can it has
the potential to overcome the language
barrier and say for example when you do
your search in English but the relevant
information is in Japanese for example
you're trying to find something about
Mount Fuji but you won't find like lots
of information when you do the search in
English it will still transfer
transferring no link knowledge
approaches go find the information in
Japanese and then bring it to you in
English it's also multimodal and it's
going to the search is going to work
using
I don't know different kinds of data
text images video audio and actually not
all of this is uh
currently there they have promised that
in 2022 so this year we're going to see
all of this happening
so this is to show that T5 is not just a
random model
and also I'm going to talk a little bit
about data driven approach or data
Centric AI
I have a question do you guys know
Andrew Angie like
yeah I assume all of you know Andrea NJ
if you if you know already you have
dealt with ML you do know him he's the
pioneer of machine learning and it's his
premise that we should switch to data
driven AI rather than model Centric AI
the thing is that when we're trying to
do the model Centric AI is like we're
holding the data fixed and iteratively
we're improving the model until the
desired results are achieved through uh
and we have to deal with a lot of noise
in the data where in this case we can
have a lot of bias coming from I don't
know fitting the making data to making
the model to feed to data but He
suggests rather to keep the model fixed
and iteratively improve the quality of
the data and
there is this proof of concept to
production Gap that it's the
renewability of AI or ml models to do
well in
when they're already in production
because of the low quality data and not
only Andrew but Google also thinks that
data is the most undervalued part of the
ML and this is the head oops I'm sorry
this part is their title page they say
that everyone wants to do the model work
not the data work it's the title page of
their their recent paper and the idea is
that like currently we have so many
powerful models through uh open source
repositories or uh I don't know the
research is there so reasonably
companies would struggle to hire I don't
know top phds but now any company can
have access to codes that like for
example Google or NASA can use it's in
the end comes down to data so why am I
talking about this approach because when
we've tried to solve this task we also
have built it around this approach on
quality data
okay now regarding the sentiment why do
we need sentiment analysis and what is
sentiment analysis I think all of us
know like uh the classic approach to
sentiment analysis which we when we try
to classify text as positive or negative
and the binary version of it but
actually we need Central analysis pretty
much in all the domains marketing
political campaign companies Management
Systems I don't know there was even a
thing done when they were tried to
predict the election results with tweet
sentiments I don't know so businesses
always want to know what their
consumers and public things about their
product and also the consumers need to
know what uh other people are thinking
about this or that product so that is
why the Whenever there is an opinion
that we can try to make sense of the
standard analysis comes to help
and actually there are different kinds
of sentiment analysis there is more
fine-grade approach when we try to
classify also the polarity of sentiment
like it's slightly negative slightly
positive
um there is aspect-based sentiment
analysis emotion detection sentiment
analysis intent based sentiment analysis
the one of our particular interest is
the aspect-based sentiment analysis so
let's try to understand what is
aspect-based sentiment analysis
um usually having just a general
sentiment of a piece of text or sentence
is not enough because like both users
and businesses want to know what exactly
is bad or good for example we can have
all these characteristics of a phone or
whatever entity it is and have those to
behave as aspects like the screen camera
I don't know the price of the phone
the performance of the phone and we can
have a review where we have the like all
the good things about this phone but in
the end it says like a battery life is
really bad so the manufacturer needs to
understand that like in this
context we have a sentiment where
towards all other entities it's positive
but towards battery life it's negative
so that I don't know you can do
something about this or ignore it I
don't know and also the consumers need
this information
so there's also targeted aspect-based
sentiment analysis where we are rather
than just identifying aspects and their
polarities we also want to identify the
target let me show you an example
okay so um
let's take a look at this one it says
the Mountain Hill Hotel was good but the
food was really bad so here we have the
mountain which is an aspect expression
of location and towards it we have a
positive sentiment and then we have
aspect expression of food and towards it
we have a negative sentiment like the
classic sentiment would fail here
because it would result in a conflict we
have both negative and positive here but
with the aspect-based one
we can have the fine-grained sentiments
toward each aspect if we make its Target
aspect-based sentiment we would also
need to identify that those aspects are
talking about the entity hotel for
example
um
also there's a different levels of
sentiment analysis it can happen
document level sentence level and entity
level
and now I want to talk a little bit
about benchmarks what is there what
research is done what data sets do we
have for sentiment the SST Stanford
sentiment Benchmark and it's a labeled
parse trees of movie review data sets
the binary version is sst2 and the fine
print version with five labels is
referred as sst5 with negative somewhat
negative neutrals and with positive and
positive labels
then for aspect based one we have the
semi Bella AP State data set it's two
domain specific data sets for laptops
and restaurants around 6000 sentences
with their specific aspects and then for
Target aspect based one we have uh
centihood it's London's neighborhoods
data set was like from Yahoo question
answering platform some sentences were
gathered and only wanted to locate the
sentences that had one or two locations
were regarded in the task because
they're when they were more than two
they they did not regard them
and the sentiments should be classified
either positive or negative
okay now let's look at the leaderboards
to see what we have for the ssd2 version
it's pretty much like the most solved
task it's around 100 percent uh the t53b
reaches that score and there are like
tons of other models that do this but
interesting things happens when we move
from binary to more fine-grained version
like for ssd5 the scores drop to 60.
um and even with Roberto large plus self
explaining we have just 60 percent here
and Roberta large I don't know if your
words actually were pretty large it's
around 360 million parameters
um
for actually I've also tried uh to see
what T5 can do on sst5 and I've got
around 54 of accuracy
but I'm pretty sure if T5 largers were
larger models were used it would have
been pretty close to Roberta
um
for the aspect-based ones we have around
90 accuracies for both Target aspect and
aspect but I want you to notice here
that like those benchmarks are a bit
broken because the data sets are very
limited constrained and when we want to
solve real world problem we just cannot
go ahead and I don't know use London
neighborhood data set when we want to
identify say different targets
uh there are also some linguistic level
challenges with sentiment analysis there
can be irony and sarcasm for example
what a great car it stopped working in
two days like the grid would say that
this is a positive but
of course this is a negative sentiment
or we can have that like a positive or
negative sentiment word may have
opposite orientations like vacuum
cleaner really sucks
sentences that include the negation this
will be his first and last Masterpiece
and sentences taken out of context
sentences that like they contain
um a sentiment word that may not express
any sentiment this usually happens with
the questions
uh and one of the hardest ones is that
when we have just factual information
and it can also contain sentiment like
after sleeping on the mattress for two
days a valley has formed in the middle
like no sentiment Expressions but of
course this is a negative connotation
and then sentences of ambiguity I can't
recommend this book too highly like this
is
not even a sentence like trying to
classify anything
um
okay now I want to present the task of
interest it's targeted sentiment
analysis on uh factual data
um where that it's a domain specific
data it can be any article like the one
I was trying to solve was regarding any
person or organization any article where
there's not much sentimentality
expressed expressed no sentiment lexicon
why am I stressing this because like
when we talk about sentiments we're
usually trying to make use of this
sentiment like lexicon like very good
very bad but when it's an article or
something more factual we don't have
that we need to understand the context
rather than the emotions or sentiments
here
uh the sentiment had to be classifieds
document level positive negative and
neutral needed to be the labels and the
same uh entity could have been in
different uh articles in one place this
person could have had a negative article
about it in another one uh positive I
don't know
so this is pretty much the task
and I wanted to I want to talk about the
data annotation since I've talked about
data Centric AI I want to say that like
we spent quite a bit of time on data
annotation and I want to thank thank our
communication linguist Marathi of
Romanian who went and did all of this
and he had all the knowledge required to
make
really good annotations that don't have
any bias so imagine we have a I don't
know some boring texts importing article
and here we have some targets different
companies or organizations and their
corresponding labels and we we need this
is basically the task having the target
identify the targets and the labels
towards each
Target like one centers can contain many
targets or actually has to be done
document level
uh why uh T5 B4 T5 we've tried like some
other choices uh Bert was the like for
the as a first choice because it's I
don't know logical to have
classification model
um
and bird is known to know to understand
context very well uh but it wasn't very
good so when we went ahead with T5
because there was this hype about T5 at
that time and
it was good I don't know it turned out
to be good T5 is standing for text to
task text transfer Transformer and it
refers all to all the tests as text to
text tasks for example
it receives the tasks as a text and
outputs a text in the end it's a
generative model
so it's an encoder decoder model I'm
going to talk a little bit about this
later so what it does to the tasks it
prevents the cell fix to the task for
example when we want to do a
summarization we say summarize then
colon and then we give the text like
first sentiment we do sentiment calling
again or for question answering you say
question there are specific
things that need to be used there so
basically it's a text to text format
and the T5 is an encoder decoder
architecture I don't know if you're
familiar with the vanilla Transformer
it's uh pretty much the same thing uses
both encoder and decoder with a little
bit of change to the positional
encodings it uses relative positional
encodings rather than
absolute or some other kinds there is
also some small changes to how the
normalization and other small things are
done but the architecture is pretty much
the same it comes T5 comes with
different sizes
the we chose the small one because it
was small and for inverse purposes
actually the main component of any kind
of Transformer is the self potential
layer self-attention is like a trunk
when we have a sequence of text says
sentence
we represent it as tokens and in the end
we want to have the same pretty much the
same encoding for the this sequence but
more contextualized like this approach
will give you say in the end each word
will attend to all the other words and
will know information about them and
we'll make it now we like it's made
multi-head because
we can have that the same word can
attend at the same time to different
other words
in the same piece of text or
I don't know sentence this is the main
mechanism of the attention
this is some visualization how I don't
know each word is connected to the
others and their
attentions
so
um actually recently it has been really
well known to pre-train the network on a
data Rich task after that to do fine
tuning on Downstream tasks so the T5
uses a
supervised and unsupervised
pure training approaches and then it's
fine-tuned on different tasks so as an
unsupervised objective it uses a mask
language modeling approach we it drops
15 percent of tokens and then tries to
I don't know
generate those tokens back the belief is
that through doing this it will
understand the language constructs it
will understand the context and in the
end any Downstream task can use this
information
uh okay so before talking about the
result results
so what we did with the T5 here actually
the T5 was then fine-tuned on sst2 so
its sentiment is basically working on
sst2 and when we give sentiment the
colon and text we'll get back a
sentiment but this approach was not
really good again because of it was like
movie review data set it was not of our
interest
the datas were totally different and
start the question answering approach
worked really well like having a good
question asking about the
now sentiment worked really well here
and then some fine tuning was done for
layer freezing optimization I don't know
in color to Contour freezing gradient
clipping different learning rate
schedulers and
I really liked the cosine and the link
Learning grade and the cosine cosine
dealing with worm restarts
um
so
with that in mind we got I don't know
some scores around 82 83 percent uh
82.83 for F1 for two labels
actually this is a bit uh different we
didn't train on two labels the one below
it's three labels negative positive and
neutral
um then we tried to see two um sorry
if concatenate the positive and neutral
ones together and create a label
positive for neutral to positive maybe
if we've trained on just binary uh
classification it would have been much
higher scores but let's remember that
this is just the T5 small and I think
the results are pretty good it's hard to
say that we can compare these two
benchmarks because again as I've said
they're like total different things but
still I think it's pretty good
so actually for preparing our text test
data set again going back to data
Centric approach we did this manually
because we went through the Articles
like we don't want to have similar
articles in the test set or we don't
want to have the same entity in the test
set we need to have it as clean as
possible and this model is now in
production we also get feedback in
production and so far didn't get any bad
emails
uh
yeah and also I wanted to talk about a
little bit about the prefix
uh the prefix that I was saying that you
append like sentiment and you give it as
a task this prefix is essentially a
hyper parameter that can be fine-tuned
uh there are prompt engineering
approaches for this the warp is an
Armenian research from yeravanan there
is also there are also other researches
there
an interesting thing is that like all
this research papers came out at the
same time so
uh T5 advices T5 says that in their
paper they say like wording doesn't
really uh
for the prefix doesn't matter much
that's why they don't do much hyper
parameter tuning there but I don't know
maybe for a specific task it can be
really helpful
so that's about it thank you if there
are any questions I'll be happy to
foreign
uh thank you for great presentation I
have two questions the first question uh
did you try maybe use only an encore
part of the five flag board uh I think
that decoyo part is needless for
sentiment analysis and other
classification tasks yeah actually we
did try it like uh just like bird the
encoder was not enough I don't know it
was weird for me that in the end it
ended up we ended up using a question
answering about accuracy was worse yes
yeah it was worse but I also have to say
that we went like back and forth through
data a lot because at some point
we made our data set bigger and we
didn't do the same experiments that we
did before having this bigger data set
so maybe on that it could have worked
cannot say that
but yeah the logical thing is to go with
modern model
and the second question did you try some
augmentation techniques for text
something like insertion or deleting
masking tokens no during supervised
learning actually no because we
use the information that was learned
there so we froze the first couple of
layers so that we can make use of this
alert information and as I've said like
the data was really well prepared so if
if I don't know since it's a bit
different data I don't think that like
augmentation and stuff could have worked
we could have had like
I know the context could have changed or
something
okay thank you
[Music]
thank you